put yourself in situations that are
uncomfortable as a comedian because you
may be a great comic but are you great
at crowd work are you great at
one-liners are you great at storytelling
are you great at roasting it's like just
try to work on all those muscles it'll
make you a better well-rounded comic and
now you're you're ready for any
situation
verse welcome back to Hot Breath the
show where you learn comedy from the
pros I'm your host comedian Joel Byers
and our guest today is the living
success story of what we preach here at
hot bread that self-made comedy hustle
one year in his career he actually drove
over 168
000 miles sleeping in his car doing Road
gigs but it all started in New York when
he was sweeping floors at Caroline's
where in this New York scene he actually
holds the record for doing 13 shows in
one night that he actually created a
documentary about available on YouTube
but since then he has self-produced his
own wait you can open that door
leave the door open for that light there
right there yeah thank you very much
speaking of self-made uh hustle that's
what we're doing here with over 400
interviews with comedians here at hot
breath but this guy is so produces his
own movies his own documentaries his own
podcast his own comedy specials where
most recently it is available on Amazon
the last late night welcome to the hot
breath versus Steve Byrne thank you so
much uh that's a hell of an introduction
you should say that every time I enter
my bedroom my wife can hear that
just come in boxer briefs I just brushed
my teeth you give that whole just meal
it'd be great all right well we can we
can clip that for you that's how I'll go
viral I'll finally blow up because I'm a
meme in bedrooms yeah yeah we've done
over 400 interviews so now you're trying
to do it Steve 401 and you're you're
someone who always likes to give back to
Young Comedians and help young comedians
what try to I mean like even tonight you
see all these Comics sitting around it's
like I know what it's like you you walk
in and you're you're there to watch the
show but in the back your head I mean
you're you're you're dreaming I hope to
God I get up tonight and uh you know
it's like yeah I mean it's no sweater
made to lose five more minutes so yeah
of course who who was who was that
comedian are those comedians for you
that really like helped you early on
I mean I'd say a lot of the New York
Comics were really really
um kind to me uh you know
you know I passed the seller maybe like
a year and a half two years in a comedy
so I got really lucky pretty quickly and
and getting to know Jim Norton and Greg
Giraldo and Rich Ross and Colin Quinn
and Robert Kelly Bill Burr you know if I
was a freshman Bobby and Bill were like
sophomores but then you had like Patrice
and Quinn and all those guys they were
like running the room running the table
and
yes they were there were a lot of
insults and very very creative insults
but at the same time you know they'd
also take you on the road with them so I
got to open for Jim Norton
got to open for Voss and Keith Robinson
and to this day those were one of the
first few times I went on the road and
really was like wow I'm working with
somebody I saw in Comedy Central this is
really cool yeah so what what do you
think now I mean you've been in the game
over 25 years and I've been in the game
13 years and just to see how it's gone
from like get on stage as much as
possible to now like comedians are
bringing in like red cams to film open
mics for crowd work yeah like the
evolution of this is like yeah gone are
the days where you could just be a
stand-up I mean you've got to be like
multi-faceted you've got to be able to
uh
[Laughter]
um but yeah you're totally right I mean
you got people that have been doing it
two or three years that are like it's
not just crowd work it's like they're
putting out specials yeah it's like
don't put that out you don't
want that out give it don't don't film
anything that's longer than 10 minutes
and put it out there if you haven't been
doing it more than 10 years you're going
to be embarrassed by it it's gonna live
forever people clip it it's going to be
embarrassing it could come back and
haunt you very few people are that good
I would say don't do it just if
you're doing stand-up comedy and it's a
real profession it's a marathon not a
Sprint so so think of the long game yeah
I didn't I self-produced a comedy
special on my 10-year anniversary so I
waited there you go 10 years to even
like try to get anything out there yeah
and it's probably really really great
had you done it five years earlier you
would have had you know probably 20
great minutes in there
um but I I would suggest to anybody 10
years 10 years for sure
so what and you're like over 25 years
did you have any moments because like
I'm I'm kind of currently going through
this and it's like
like pre-pandemic I was starting to do a
lot of Comedy zones I was getting like
some headlining roading work and I was
about to be on the road a lot more and
then all of a sudden overnight I'm
unemployed and then it kind of hit me of
like
I mean am I even about that life like
it's I've kind of been gone back and
forth I'm like I mean do I want to be
out on the road where I'd rather be home
in my family do I need to find other
ways like sure did you ever go through
anything like that in your career well I
go through it all the time I mean I go
through it now I've been doing this 25
years and you mentioned all those
credits and still it's like
you're still trying to everybody goes to
reps and flows in their career I don't
care how big you are right now there's a
lot of comics that are very doing very
well but
you're gonna hit that you know the Peaks
and valleys and I had a great Peak and
I've had a really low valley and I'm
crawling out of it now it's it's it's
really hard to do it once it's extremely
difficult to do it twice and so that's
what I'm up against right now and you
know I think with like the last late
night and these projects I'm working on
maybe that'll take me over the hump the
next round but I've always made my bread
and butter on at the clubs and it's been
great but uh but yeah I mean you know it
definitely there definitely is a fatigue
factor that comes into like Jesus Christ
I gotta go to the airport and
you could be at the nicest hotel in the
world but it's still not your home and
FaceTiming the kids and the misses it
just it it does wear on you but then
it's also like
but your Gypsy this is what you
signed up for and this is what you
dreamed about when you were in your 20s
when you're in your 20s you dream
about doing this so it's like you also
can't take it for granted what what is
what was the valley what what value did
you just go through well I I think there
there's you know I had a TV show I had a
documentary a feature film that comes
out during pandemic like you know once
the the show kind of ended you kind of
dipped down again and you gotta like
re-establish yourself so it's like the
dock the the film but there's just all
the elements of business that come into
this and ticket sales and managers and
agents and representation ultimately
what it comes down to is relevance are
you relevant or not and I think to truly
make it in this business you gotta have
at least one hit you gotta have a hit
you can get on base all you want and
I've always gotten on base I never had a
problem with that but I just the thing
that eluded me is a genuine hit you know
um some people have a hit via podcast
some people have a hit via an hour
special that came at the right time on
the right platform that everybody heard
about
um but I always been consistent in terms
of work and producing and creating but
it just you know I wouldn't say Sullivan
and Son was a hit I wouldn't say the
opening act was a hit I wouldn't say
that Jonathan dock was hit they're all
Sweat Equity it's all a lot of passion
and there's an education in it and so
I've learned to do a hell of a lot more
than a lot of other comedians I can
bring assets to the table of writing
directing starring and producing in
cobbling you know assembling packaging
I've got a good
I got a good uh education on the
landscape of the industry itself but
again it's like you just keep putting
yourself in that batter's box and
praying okay maybe this is the one and
then you get Tailwinds you can kind of
ease up a little bit but uh I wouldn't
even say when you when you get that hit
you can still ease up because you still
have to keep the relevance that's even
harder than gaining it is actually keep
it yeah I mean what Tom Cruise has done
is remarkable I mean you look at
somebody like that or Tom Hanks they've
had losses they've had films that are
bombed like Tom Cruise The Mummy but
then he's still relevant in these
Mission Impossible movies the top gun
Maverick I mean the guys you know 60 and
he's flipping around in airplanes it's
crazy well that's why I was the
most successful film ever you saying Tom
made me think like Tom Segura or like
Bert Kreischer who just kept swinging
and swinging and swinging and then sure
boom you know well I think the
difference with those guys is that they
were never industry Darlings right
industry was always about you know Ivy
League schools the pedigree the resume
and then the industry would never anoint
people like that and so then you had a
bunch of guys that said well it I
got a Wi-Fi I got a camera and I'm gonna
go out and you know stake my own claim
and now those podcasts are bigger than
anything that they would audition for or
pitch to any of the streamers or the
networks I mean they're making more
money now than you would if you got a
series at Netflix so it's like why would
you want a series of Netflix if you're
in that situation ride that out as long
as you can six figures second seven
figures no Executives telling what you
can or can't do in fact you're being
rewarded for the things you can't say
by saying I'm on a podcast yeah so
um I guess it's always so relative I
mean it's like for me a comedian and US
comedians like see you and are like oh
my gosh she's done these movies these
documentaries he just released an Amazon
special like sure oh he's he's killing
it but then on the other side you're
like I mean you know but it is more
right yeah of course I mean everybody
wants more I think it's kind of the
nature of the game
um yeah you're always going to be kind
of like looking in the rear view and
looking in front of you and seeing what
your friends are up to and everything
and as unhealthy as it is you also want
to be supportive of those people because
any individual in this industry knows
how difficult it is it's hard
it's really hard so anybody that gets
that semblance of success it's like
celebrate it for sure Pat them person on
the back because it's hard
do you have any advice for me and where
I'm at right for you 13 years in I'm on
a couch this is therapy now yes therapy
now um
I I would just think whatever it is that
that that comes your way as you go go
down the line I mean you look you're
doing this this is important
um for free but for over five years but
that's that's another part of it I think
so much of what you do is going to be
free until you've proven yourself right
and so the Sullivan and Son I wrote on
spec that means free I wrote the opening
act on spec the second script I wrote on
spec sold it to Will Smith it's like all
these things you could go out and pitch
it to these people and wait for them to
give you money but if you're an unproven
commodity you gotta write it you
got to swing on yourself you always got
to better in yourself and the good news
is you're betting on yourself you're
creating something you're sticking with
it and you're out there hustling you're
doing stand-up I would just recommend
that as you get more involved in the
industry as the opportunity is open for
yourself don't hesitate to walk in that
door and see if you can learn a bit more
like I would never have written Sullivan
and Son or the opening act without you
know friends pushing me to say you can
do it it's like really you think I can
do this and then doing it and now I
understand narrative now I can watch a
movie and understand the Beats at five
minutes 12 minutes 25 45 55 and 75 and
85 like I know structure now and so I
know what story is and it's because of
the education I have and working with
some really talented people over the
years that have been patient with me to
say this is how this works and so now
because I went in just thinking I don't
know let's see and I'll give it my best
shot and when you do
and really invest in the opportunity you
I think you'll really be surprised at
how much better of a performer and all
around entertaining you'll be if you put
yourself in those situations uh even
with stand up you know I did a lot of
crowd work tonight crowd works of muscle
I've been working on with the new
special monologue jokes never did that
up until the challenge of saying do a
late night talk show as a stand-up now
doing that now understanding the Cadence
and flow and writing of those jokes it's
like I wouldn't have done that if I
didn't challenge myself to say do
something different this time do a late
night talk show right so so storytelling
not the best Storyteller but I forced
myself to sit down in the special and
tell stories again all those things are
different muscles and stand up people
think oh just go roast them it's
like roasting is a muscle we'll just go
up and do crowd work crowd work's a
muscle and I think the more you put
yourself in Harry's situations say I'm
going to force myself to just do
one-liners tonight I'm going to force
myself to just do crowd work tonight I
think all those things will just make
you a better well-rounded comedian so
when you're either hosting the Golden
Globes or you're hosting for the
Rotary Club and somebody drops a glass
there's a drunk guy like tonight that
came up and just entered this like I'm
literally prepared for anything that
could happen and I know my way
in and out of it I can still control the
room and it's only because I force
myself to put myself in situations like
that so for like a show that's what I
recommend to you is to is to put
yourself in situations that are
uncomfortable as a comedian because you
may be a great comic but are you great
at crowd work are you great at
one-liners are you great at storytelling
are you great at roasting it's like just
try to work on all those muscles it'll
make you a better well-rounded comic and
now you're you're ready for any
situation
yeah I think for the first 10 years I
was like very scripted in like every
line I've pre-prepared and I've written
and it's almost like a script sure so
now I am trying to be a little more like
organic on stage still having directions
but maybe being a more loose in how I
get to the difference yeah I mean if you
have you know let's say you have seven
sets scheduled for the week
take five of them do your material and
take two of them and one of them just
say I'm just gonna do crowd work and the
other one say I'm gonna work on
one-liners or I'm gonna work on
storytelling you know whatever your
weaknesses are yeah I would say do that
because when I was in New York City I
always made sure if I was doing six sets
a night or four sets tonight I would
always dedicate one to just crowd work
and so that has got me to the point
where the last three years especially
it's like a totally different I don't
know it's like you can have your black
belt then and I was like oh my God
something's clicking lately where the
last three years the crowd work is just
some something where I really enjoy
doing it what what clicked for you what
do you think changed and I brought you a
water as well that's no I appreciate it
thankful yeah I saw that I wasn't sure
if that was something else but I think
what clipped it was was just the
confidence to go just trust yourself
put yourself in a situation dig as deep
of a hole as you can and then dig
yourself out of it so I would find
somebody and I'd say almost something so
offensive I was like oh my God I can't
believe I'm saying this but now it's
like all right figure it out now and
that was it and so once I did that now
it's like it's flawless I don't
know I just really I don't mean to
Pat myself on the back yeah yeah
but it's like it's really great
I mean even tonight there's I mean I'm
talking this 18 year old girl with her
parents saying she takes it up
the ass she's a she's
laughing the parents are laughing and
you're not doing it in a mean-spirited
way you're still doing it and having fun
and winking at them and then doing a
pendulum swing to this 18 year old kid
with who's with his parents and then
just learning how to play everybody off
each other and constantly having the
Rolodex flipping of going she's a
dentist she said this she said that and
knowing when to when to pull the trigger
on those things it's it's it's a lot of
fun it's it's pretty hard hard but once
you once you get it oh see you're
spinning the plates it's fun yeah and I
feel like so many young Comics now they
want the crowd work clip for like Tick
Tock but like where should young where
do you think you're saying learn all
these different things a lot of them
aren't good at it though exactly they're
bad and they start like it's
crowd workers they start with one-liners
like what what is like a young comic
need to start like what do you think's
the foundation well I think look if you
if you want to do crowd work then post
it but the the audience is always going
to tell you what's good or not and I'm
telling you in my Facebook feed or my
Twitter feed or my Tick Tock I
see a lot of shitty crowd work
it's bad please stop everybody's
ruining it Andrew Schultz did it great
he was the first to kind of like post
those things then everybody did
it and there's very few Jessica
Pearson's great I never film mine and I
should but I just uh it's it there's a
lot of out there for sure yeah and
they're posting like five second little
Snippets of light and then that's all
they got yeah yeah exactly but it's just
it's weird that we're all with the
internet now like what Schultz is like
crazy we're all just trying to find our
angle in on the comedy game and people
are trying to skip the being funny part
I guess is the first thing yeah but it
just again it comes with time you know
if you're if you're doing this for the
long haul you know the cream will rise
to the top so it just it's a matter of
perseverance and you've been doing this
13 years and um you know it doesn't
sound like you're gonna get a tech job
or work in a cubicle so so you're Off to
the Races yeah you're fine so what as uh
as we land This Plane here
um something I always ask comedians as
we're talking about struggling on stage
is like their worst bombing or their
worst like booze story
um like what what comes to mind that
just gives you PTSD
um I don't know that I have PTSD from
anything I think any of the worst bombs
was always a lesson right so there was
one where I was like two or three years
in
uh these kids are standing up working
over their bill I'm trying to pacify the
situation
they keep talking they're ignoring me
um I say something to one kid he says
something really racist back to me this
girl says something and I say something
really offensive back to her and next
thing I know a bar stool gets chucked
splits the back of my head open I got
eight Staples and what happened was I
went to the emergency room that day I
got eight Staples I go back to the comic
strip the next day because I'm like I'm
still gonna perform I don't give
a I was concussed but you know I
didn't really know much on it and then
on my headshot people taped Staples to
my headshot and called me the chairman
which again I think is hilarious
but the cops called and said do you want
to press charges you know we we reviewed
it with the club we know who it is by
the credit card and I said no because
it's my lesson to learn and the lesson
was
when you're a stand-up comedian you
can't
you can't lose control of the room you
can't let your emotions get the best of
you you always got to rise above it and
be better and it was that situation that
told me okay keep your cool
always maintain levity in the room and
be a professional and I wasn't
professional in that moment so I deserve
to have that happen to me as much as
maybe I should have pressed charges who
knows it was still my lesson to learn it
was a tough lesson to learn but it's a
lesson that I never forgot and
it made me a much better comic so it's
you know you never learn from successes
you always learn from the failures and
uh and that was a major one for me
um the only thing that success brings is
just you know more whiskey you're like
of course like when there's success
you're like of course I killed of course
I got this I'm the chosen one yeah yeah
yeah yeah of course yeah yeah it's
me yeah what do you want to do next like
did you just say is your Amazon did you
say it's your last special uh well it's
called the last late night because it's
talk shows are are dying they're not as
relevant so that's why I called it the
last late night it was like a way to pay
homage to it but I'll be honest with you
I don't think our specials are relevant
I don't think they'll ever be relevant I
don't think people give a anymore I
think if anything they watch 15 minutes
of a Netflix or Amazon and or wherever
the they're watching it and they
may come back to it or not but really
where they're seeing it is on our phone
you're seeing Clips you're seeing it all
broken down so why put the production
value into it why do it unless you know
for 10 of the comedians it makes for a
great spectacle but it's like you could
still film that all for a lot less
because it's just going to end up on
somebody's phone in a 30 second minute
long clip that's where everybody's
getting it and
after doing that last hour I'm just like
I don't know I'm not even motivated to
write anything again I'm around
I'm doing crowd work I'm doing these
monologue jokes it's a lot of fun but I
still got to figure out the next step I
don't know you don't know what you want
to do next no clue I mean I've got three
scripts on the back burner one's about
to go uh that I'll I've written that
I'll direct
um and uh other than that I just you
know I'm doing these podcasts revamping
those out of New York City and I'll
start filming a lot more the crowd work
the next year and putting it up and
showing people what the real crowd
working like so I'm excited about that
yeah but other than that I think the
world of stand-up is changing so fast
again like to your point I'm trying to
figure figure it out for myself but I I
just uh a little disillusion right now
with it all because I just after you do
something like the last late night which
nobody else has done anything like it
you're just like what now what now
because that's so outside of the box so
I I don't know I got it figured out
yeah we know that's so funny that I'm 13
years I'm like I don't know and you're
25 years ago like I don't know but then
there's I don't know one year Comics are
like I don't know nobody knows but I
think you just want it whatever it is
you're doing you want to have fun you
want to be proud of it and I'm certainly
proud of the of the last late night for
sure yeah it's a beautiful special so
well produced and uh the last thing we
end this with is like any uh favorite
closing advice for young Comics out
there closing advice for young Comics I
would just say uh just do the
work there's so many there's so many
people that don't want to do the work
and um
whether it's just getting up whether
it's being professional whether it's
working on new material whether it's
pushing yourself
um it's it's shocking to me over the
last few years even working on projects
and throwing out offers to people seeing
how lazy comedians are it's
bananas to me I'm really blown away and
that's why I've always had confidence in
myself because I'm like well I know this
I'll outwork everybody no matter
who it is so um
it's it's mind-blowing how lazy Comics
are I'm really I I don't even know what
to say just blown away I could I
could rattle off some big names in terms
of people you'd just be like what
lazy really crazy crazy how how
much people want to be spoon fed or how
they don't want to think outside the box
or how they don't want to create or
write for themselves it's mind-blowing
to me and that's that's why a lot of the
you know Elder Statesman of the comedy
scene in terms of like feature films
right you think about
you know when's the last time you saw a
good R-rated comedy but a lot of those
guys Will Ferrell Ben Stiller Vince
Vaughn Owen Wilson
um Adam Sandler the common theme
all those great comedic voices have in
terms of feature is that they all write
for themselves they're not just doing
sketch they all are very Hands-On in
terms of story development and narrative
and a lot of comics are bubbling up and
they don't want to take the time to
learn narrative they don't want to take
the time to learn how to write for
themselves they just want to be pitching
you know uh paired with somebody that's
going to write for themselves and then
two or three years in then they
get it and then it's too late so I would
strongly suggest picking up a book like
save the cat which is one of the easiest
books to read on narrative in terms of
the feature space and and once you learn
that I think it makes you a better
performer you appreciate features and
then you appreciate you know when you
have the opportunity you have two or
three projects to give a manager an
agent a production company uh and not
enough Comics have have done the work to
to get there so perfect yeah well do you
mind uh just looking at the camera
saying your name and why people should
listen to hot breath hey I'm Steve Byrne
you should list in a hot breath because
because
that's why okay it's got everything you
need it's got comics it's got great a
great hairline
uh uh look at this this is every kid
that that's massacring a school with an
AR-15 right here
with a microphone
don't let that foolish don't let that
smile fool you it's a angry guy
trust me all right breath